are you hyper
sensitive yeah do you feel real big do
you ever get overwhelmed by your Fe yeah
yeah yes but I do think this is really
good news because I think when you're
over sensitive you also overthink and
over feel and if anyone is saying that
being a sensitive person is a superpower
it can like try to help switch that
narrative a little bit because maybe our
own narrative isn't the best sometimes I
think if you're a sensitive person
you're probably very sensitive towards
others and things and you know all the
nouns people places things but like can
you turn that sensitivity back on
yourself like that's something I
struggle with like all the room and
empathy in the world for everybody else
not a lot of patience and Grace for
myself but I I like that we're saying
being a sensitive person is a superpower